ici le lido de venise
décidément je n'aimerais pas être à la
place du jury de ce festival car
jusqu'ici on n'a pas vu grand chose
seuls deux films retiennent l'attention
mais pour des raisons diverses ils ont
peu de chances d'emporter la palme
le premier de ces films c'est celui de
bunuel simon du dr simon le styliste
magnifique poème très bel exercice de
style dans lequel on retrouve tous les
thèmes chers à bunuel mais justement
nous sommes ici en italie
et vous savez qu'en italie on n'apprécie
pas tellement le blasphème
de ce fait simon le désert fera sans
doute écarté et puis il y a le film de
jean luc godard qui vient d'être
présenté pierrot le fou labour jean luc
hess que pierrot le fou c'est l'histoire
du fait divers c'est l'histoire de
pierre loutrel n'ont absolument pas non
non c'est l'histoire d'un type
il s'appelle même pas pierrot s'appelle
ferdinand dur stcc la fille dont il est
amoureux ski qu'il appelle pierrot pour
l'énerver il lui répète sans arrêt je
m'appelle ferdinand que lui dit que four
français
c'est un surnom vous faites par les lits
fort barça voit que ça correspond
l'histoire de l'art par aziz a au début
il y il y un truc d'histoire de l'art
trouve qui correspond à ses aumont qui
commence
un peu c'est un film sur la pâte on va
pas sur la peinture mais qui est je
crois un film qui ressemble que plus un
tableau inquiet plus à un paysage comme
comment font les peindre un portrait à
la fois paysager reporteraient leurs au
début je pense mon propos était le même
qu'un peintre se trouvait que c'est un
immense pas être de la sq s comparaison
est un peu haute mais qu'il semblait
bien jean-luc godard êtes vous un
provocateur
entendons nous bien ce n'est pas
injurieux est-ce qu'on peut vouloir
avancer provocateur c'est ben non on
peut vouloir aussi bien provoquer
l'admiration
l'étonnement que la colère à l'enfance
la nom provoque un événement c'est ça me
fera pas provocateur offense policiers
du module ans oui disent ah oui enfin je
veux dire vous aimez bien étonné par
exemple banon mais il se trouve que si
les ans endormie et qu'un qu'il ya des
choses qui font du bruit ben ça les
réveils s'ils étaient endormis s'ils
sont éveillés déjà salée réveille pas du
tout anne a parlé nous d'abord de votre
pierrot le fou c'était
c'est un personnage assez extraordinaire
dans le sens que c'est une fille qui
beaucoup de choses à la fois elle et mes
chances et les vicieuses elle
romantique des sangsues montage
l es tu dans le suis mais
tout de suite après
et d'une vitesse à compléter c'est que
vous êtes en très souvent le l'agent
d'un destin si nico d'art oui mais là je
crois que c'est un personnage qui qui
est tous les rôles que j'ai fait c'est à
dire c'est à la fois une femme est une
femme vivre sa vie le suis soldat
bande à part c'est un peu plus tard sur
ne pensait pas vous êtes là la femme
fatale 1965 finalement non non je crois
pas dans ce sens que ce que j'aime faire
ces jeunes changer de tout jeu j'aime
vivre qu'à n'importe quoi alors je crois
pas que ce soit seulement patin je
comprends qu'une c'est ça
ayew
c'est jamais peut-être mais j'aimerais
beaucoup